[Music]
Dylan O'Brien returns to the silver
screen in American assassin after
sustaining serious injuries on the set
of Maze Runner the death cure all the
training was very good for my mind and
very good for recovery in a way and
eliminate the target yes sir
[Music]
were you ever apprehensive about moving
into another high action movie like this
oh absolutely yeah yeah yeah the state
that you're in
you know after something like that is
you know it's you just want to run from
all that stuff I was yeah didn't really
even want to leave my couch necessarily
when I was allowed to so yeah that was a
you know this it was a big step doing
this I don't know how close you can get
how close he can't get how do we what
side do I flip him along because I don't
want to hit that area and so it was it
made it harder but in a way was was
better I really did like I loved I was
very fascinated with all the the fight
training and the gun training and
probably you know most challenging
probably just at the time it came in and
what I was coming off of I was I was
still at the very end of recovery there
and this whole thing is just a means to
an injury you know
this is just a beginning what's the
latest you can give us on Maze Runner we
completed it I'm looking forward to
seeing some footage soon and stuff and
our goal is to go in and finish it with
a bang and hope to try to make the you
know best movie out of the three and and
I think you know I think it's gonna be
going I think I think we did good work
and it really good crew down there in
South Africa a really good experience
and really good for me to put it away on
a nice positive note too and yeah so
yeah it's exciting excited about
[Music]
you